ladies thank you very much
this was really fun I love you very much
and I'm sorry I'm sorry that I have to
live like this you have to do this job
and I mean this is so no I'm happy for
you but I thought you meant you know how
I took that that you're sorry that I
have to be me
like that I I'm not sorry for that I'm
glad about that
right that regular glad so think about
it alone you think about me plenty
I sure do you think about me constantly
you call me constantly and so does why
do you think his tongue is out where's
look that's how much he liked my
performance anyway everything Andy does
the same thing sometimes what is your
job and his tongue just hangs hang out
sometimes and yeah and I was with a
French Bulldog I was waiting the entire
time for the farting oh man I was gonna
ask if we could mic it just to be sure
we go you can hang a painting no I can't
what I'm gonna do later after after I
retire hanging paintings on darm parts I
already had the website I think we have
35 pull quotes from this interview alone
they're gonna go on in instant me it's a
classy show go back
you've done you've taken our show to a
new height this is actually raising the
bar I'm so short because what I say goes
up and I add on to that sentence and
make it pretty graphic
this will never none of this is airing
this interview went exactly as it
started exactly as I knew it would and
it ended exactly
oh we're wrapping this up now I've
called the police hey thanks for
watching be sure to click subscribe to
see even more great Conan clips you may
now return to your pirated movies and
creepy Japanese pornography